Oh told you okay why don't we stop it
here move it no reason to fight
[Music]
[Music]
so uh feel really good today
tough flight like a 7 p.m. New York to
Europe is tough because your timings off
but had three different sessions of two
three hours sleep so got it in Dublin is
a gorgeous town
get in there brother it's gorgeous
really enjoy my stay so far I've had
some productive meetings you know what's
kind of cool right now over here what's
kind of cool right now is uh you know
with vaynermedia UK opening Europe is in
play so I I always say I love being Gary
Vaynerchuk CEO and I play Gary Vee
anytime I'm in Gary Vee mode which is
once every three years for three or four
weeks when I'm doing book stuff I I
struggle with that cuz I know it's not
my favorite zone believe it or not I
want to be in my operating mode and so
being able to do the meetings that I
just did that are more predicated on
vaynermedia's growth in the European
market they would strategize and say and
videos they would strategize and say
infographics they would strategize and
say audio podcast they would strategize
and then we would produce and then we
deploy so it's kind of interesting I
think it's really fascinating that the
two places that most people are cynical
around social media b2b and performance
space like does them like is it black
and white
ROI are the two places that we as a
company are most confident in I know I'm
right like a hundred percent right you
want you're gonna go project manage the
building of a consumer app you 100%
can't do it that was loaded I was in a
great zone oh god there was a lot there
I have a really interesting idea I
literally think something titled jam
session with Gary Vee could be an
unbelievable bit of people are selling
hard work without actually doing it it's
really easy to tweet hustle yeah it's
you know it's a whole different thing to
actually do it and as video is evolving
and as my career's evolving and as
technology is evolving it's a long time
ago I said it was gonna be harder and
harder to hide and I think this is not a
joke I think one of the reasons I'm
aggressively storytelling with having a
man follow me around and videotape and
now what snapchat is I want to pressure
the other people in this space to show
me show me could you do a video yeah
basically as my alarm in the morning
yes he saw absolutely gas Cameron
Cameron Cameron it's Gary Vee get the
[ __ ] up my man
Pam let's get this cam let's get this
today one life baby
one life Cameron you got it stay well
take care alright thank you now I can
feel with a with a with a with no no
heavy conscious now I can go onstage and
rip and I mean rip everybody's faces off
here in Dublin
[Applause]
who's an entrepreneur in here raise your
hand let me give you one really really
good piece of advice
speed is four billion times more
important than perfection the amount of
you that are crippled by getting [ __ ]
right instead of getting [ __ ] done is
insane and it is an absolute variable to
success in an entrepreneur land where
you have to do something in those couple
years or you're [ __ ] dead the selfies
I don't know if you're gonna use a d-roc
the selfie thing is out of control you
guys meet you what's your name Mary Kate
Mary Kate how are you good good so nice
to meet you thank you you tricked me
here we go awesome thanks Claire bye-bye
oh my god you got it
once you open up Pandora's box right
thank you thank you you got it you got
it it's a done deal
Arak approved a DVD my man what's his
name says Connor Connor he called you
his Pope Connor scary V okay the Pope
super pumped to see you in a little bit
your homies are here just a lot of fun
just it's I will never I'm gonna make a
promise on dailyvee right now never a
zygote when I buy the Jets and have to
stand in the stadium and for 74 thousand
strong selfie it up after we win the
Superbowl like it's so crazy to like be
a big deal in like yeah you know like in
Ireland I will never ever ever ever ever
ever not be grateful and humbled and
blown away by by people's respect and
admiration and to take off micro second
take a selfie I mean I just got off the
plane and there was a kid to throw ours
to pitch me I was in no mood to be
pitched even I even I kind of answered
first he's like hey can I tell you I was
like not now can I get to the hotel and
he's like I drove and I don't know and I
was like fine let's do it like so that's
been interesting that's been intense the
love has been amazing here in Dublin
great tech seen a lot of entrepreneurial
spirit I I love my trip to Sydney this
is no Sydney I love you but I'd be lying
if I didn't say I felt some
unique energy so far maybe that's just
because I've been a little bit more out
about that I wasn't Sydney so I don't
want anybody else trolley oppressor
let's go do with you rock pumps show huh
really show
cool cool go get the stoner yes do it
yeah thanks for coming guys
I love it you like it I love it it's
gorgeous
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 192 in the ask gary vee
show live from Dublin Oh
told you okay two minutes we're fine
so why don't why don't we stop in here
move it let's move no reason to fight
[Music]
yeah
and talent
on this episode I go in the startup van
cool guys stay well guys were you in the
talk yeah
remember what I said stop doing perfect
do fast send your work to everybody
who's in the business I sat in my store
for 12 hours a day and answered every
single [ __ ] person's wine question I
mean I guarantee I can taste that you've
never sat for 12 hours on Twitter and
hit everybody
I get it every day do you understand do
you understand like literally every day
Steven Spielberg hey [ __ ] I don't
know Clint Tarantino hey and then
thousand people I don't know but you
know cuz you know the game do you
understand thanks for coming bro but not
yet can you get Alex can you get Alex to
get my bags in the start of fan-like
we're gonna have to be tight
ya know I know
you don't know super well brother thanks
for some of your tweets
nice pleasure and thanks for doing that
for us bathroom day thanks for having me
here sup guys it's gary vee jim balan
our that's what we do huh get on get on
get up
you got it no worries
awesome take care bye guys
hope you just gotta walk right in
awesome eight still ah drive my phone
yeah doing my passport more importantly
[Music]
great day in dublin just got to uh
Heathrow we're in Heathrow right there
Heathrow London bringing the fire big
time d-roc you didn't need to look at
what I just saw
[Applause]
[Music]
you